[Music]
and then welcome to the inaugural
edition of Silent Bob speaks with Kevin
Smith can't believe it took me that long
to figure out a title for these normally
I kind of just put things under Fatman
beyond or just throw them up now any
time I'm sitting here talking to camera
we got a name for it it's a name that's
been around for a long ass time okay
but on this inaugural edition man I'm
gonna review spider-man : far from home
you can watch me and mark barnard and
review spider-man far from home on fat
man Beyond which goes up tomorrow we did
it at scum and villainy and everybody
was there everybody took everybody to
see the movie at a screen X viewing of
the flick where the movie wraps around
you it's awesome and then we all sat
around and talked about it and stuff so
you could watch me and Mark talk about
it and all the folks at the cantina who
were there for the show talked about it
tomorrow today I'm gonna give you my one
on one right here man with the very
first Silent Bob speaks branding kids
okay so before we do that a little
housekeeping just to you know pay the
bills and stuff here we go if you're
going to comic-con the San Diego
comic-con comic-con international it's
San Diego a celebration of the popular
arts I'll be there this year as I have
been for the last three years sitting in
back at a hall age and back at the
entire Convention Center in the water on
the IMD boat where I'm going to be
interviewing my my pop culture betters
all weekend long and stuff and then on
Saturday the 20th night of the 20th
I have my panel on in Hall H right after
the Marvel panel so [ __ ] you know what
am I gonna say after that I'll tell you
what I'm gonna say after that man I'm
gonna show you a trailer I'm gonna bring
the Jay and Silent Bob reboot trailer
with me and my bring Jay with me as well
and we're gonna show you a scene from
the movie you know because the trailer
will go up online but this scene from
the movie we're only if you're in Hall H
you're gonna see it if not you see it
when you finally see the movie
comes out so that's what I'm doing in in
San Diego and then lastly Hollywood
babble-on with me and Ralph Garman
returns to the improv on Saturday July
27 week after comic-con all right so
there's some housekeeping for you let's
dive in I've seen spider-man far from
home twice now first time I saw it in
screen X the good folks at screen X set
up a screening for us and had a absolute
blast it was only like five of us in the
theater it was a private screening so
second time I watch six before I like to
review stuff or this barely a review
there's a recap really I like to make
sure I see it again so I remember
everything because I'm ablaze most of
the time so I won't make sure I get
details so I went to see it when I was
in Cleveland
I just went to Cleveland to do a show at
Youngstown State University in Ohio so I
was in Cleveland at night before I said
[ __ ] it man I'm gonna go see spider-man
the the in that morning so I went in the
morning to check it out and it was a 10
o'clock screening so you know I was
there's no slam whatsoever on on you
know where I was in the world and stuff
like that but you know before you go do
a show I was gonna go do a show in
Youngstown you look it up see you later
what can I talk about you know you're
someone hit the stage dry and be like
[ __ ] goes on here you know you want
to have a working familiarity so you
could be like hello Cleveland or
something like that so I looked up
Youngstown and in its Wikipedia
breakdown like there's a section that
you rarely see for most cities sit crime
and I was like that's funny and I
clicked on it and it said at the base of
the heading at the everything was a lot
of information in it and it said
Youngstown is the ninth most dangerous
city in the United States not in Ohio in
the United States so I was like oh
that's I had no idea that's where I was
so I didn't want to leave my laptop in
my hotel room so I brought my laptop
with me in a bag no judgment against the
hotel
the people and staff at the hotel they
were all wonderful but you know number
nine in a nationwide like that's big
number so I was like you know what just
in case somebody decides to get into my
room let me take my laptop laptops got
scripts I'm organized got the movie it's
goods everything right so take the
laptop I put it in my bag I can just
carry the laptop so I put it in my bag
got Zack and Miri Make a Porno like bag
from when we wrapped the movie so
putting that got some room in the bag so
I'm like [ __ ] I'm going to movie
theater man bring some snacks so I
brought some vegan snacks I'm vegan I
don't know if you know this but a big so
I want got some snacks at Whole Foods
because if you go get the snacks movie
theater generally speaking they don't
have you know vegan options and I'm not
like I ain't cheap I'm happy to pay
whatever they charge me to movie theater
but if you had the snacks you have my
brands I'll be buying y'all snacks but
if not you know since I'm bringing a bag
already I'm like all right I'm Brinks
cuz it was early in the morning so I'll
bring some stuff cuz I eat it noon I
know people like get to the review you
fat piece of [ __ ] they don't say that
anymore get to review you dumb piece of
[ __ ] you're formally Pepys's yet so I
had some snacks in the bag pack some
snacks in and stuff and I go to the
movie you know got my ticket went inside
was packed I had to sit between people
it was lay back recliner so it was
totally fine to my right there's a lady
right next to her some older dude like
in his 30s to my left there's a little
kid you know eight nine maybe ten or so
I can't judge a cop day he was just
small person like young hidden next to
him is his mom next to the mom is the
other brother she keeping him apart
it was I will say it was durable
spoilers at one point when spider-man
and MJ spoilers finally kissed the kid
next to me went nuts like but not in the
fanboy way like I did my heart soared
but this kid was like ahhh and he
squirmed and literally put his face into
his mother I was like wow man I remember
those days so there I am getting ready
to watch a movie that putting up the
trailers man
a goldfinch trailer and I'm like how the
[ __ ] they're gonna adapt this book like
look at that [ __ ] hold it don't it it's
that Ansel boy and so what's his [ __ ]
and I'm watching the trailer all sudden
flashlight goes in my face and the
security guard is standing in front of
me and he goes hi what's in the bag and
I was like but this bag I was a guy and
I felt [ __ ] caught man like really
[ __ ] caught like I wasn't expecting
that and I you know I was it was weird
what was weirder was remember the guy
who's sitting next to the lady I talked
about about five minutes prior to this
like he was staring at me hardcore
before like the trailers popped in and
you know I was just like that happens
cuz like oh you know I dress like
[ __ ] Silent Bob everyday in my life
so with the backwards baseball cap
people like oh it's that [ __ ] hey
it's Kevin James so I thought I got
recognized
Kwasi recognized you know and so I
didn't every time I looked over him a
man would like look away and [ __ ] like
that
so I thought like oh I'm used to this I
know this game I've done this a zillion
to that so that guy got up at one point
like just when the trailers begin I just
marked it I don't know why because he
was looking at me when he got up and
then security dude like comes in and
kind of look in the bag
and I'm like what why why am I who the
[ __ ] would profile me like [ __ ] do I
look like someone who's here to start
some [ __ ] I look like [ __ ] Kevin
James man so uh you know I'm like
[ __ ] nervous cuz I got a bunch of
snacks in my bag too so I'm like oh [ __ ]
so I'm like I thought for a second maybe
that's what he was asking me about him
like these [ __ ] are so tight
with the no snacks policy Jesus Christ I
go Mike my laptop and he goes may I see
it
and I said uh okay and so I unzip the
back pockets what a laptop is and he
looks in with a flashlight and he goes
okay thank you and then walks away and I
was like that's so [ __ ] up like me but
like I said there's a lady with a purse
like there are people all over then the
dude who got up he comes and sits down
and that's when I put it together man my
man
profile
me and was like there's a loner nutbag
who came in just before the movie began
he's got a bag in his lap and he looks
awfully suspect and he [ __ ] they
thought I might be trouble me of all
people man
meanwhile the [ __ ] kid next to me a
little kid is staring at me suddenly
because he's like the worst thing in the
world you can do in front of a child is
have security come up to you because now
this kid's like your suspect and so you
know a couple minutes into the movie and
[ __ ] I flip the bag around and I go open
it up real quietly and slowly because
I'm reaching in to get my [ __ ] snacks
man movies under way there's a nice kind
of loud sequence so I'm like they won't
hear - crinkling of the bag I reach in
to get these these whole foods like
peanut butter snacks I got and as I pull
out my bags open I look over and the kid
next to me has just seen the wealth of
snacks in my bag and he's wide-eyed he
looks up at me and I look at him and he
goes I'm telling the man and I was a
girl please don't this all before the
movie begins an adventure before the
movie so his mother tells him to leave
me alone we go back to watching the
[ __ ] flick I'm eating my snacks loving
this film second time I saw it let's
jump into it look before we recap the
movie and order of things of how they
happen this is generally what I try to
do is just retell the story I got a jump
look like here let's do this a preview
before the review or app recap for the
recap not only is this one of the best
superhero movies ever made not only is
this pure cinematic joy along the order
of you know Empire Strikes Back or
Raiders of the Lost Ark same feelings I
had when I saw those movies in a movie
theater when I was a kid not only is
this movie a time machine to a better
time of your life this movie plays like
a happy childhood not only does this
movie capture everything that movies are
supposed to be about escape wonder
adventure heroism drama characters not
only is it
Avengers 1.5 and as much as it dub tales
directly off of endgame
and shows us what the Marvel Universe
looks like today now that the spoilers
Tony Stark has given his life and I
should say before we go any deeper into
this spoilers spoilers spoilers we're
gonna like spoil his [ __ ] out of
spider-man far from home so if you're
watching this you haven't seen the movie
stop go see the movie come back continue
watching this not only is this movie one
of my favorite Marvel movies ever made
not only does this movie manage to not
only you know make endgame tastier
somehow an end game was a tasty buffet
not only does this movie spider-man far
from him add a flavor to that buffet
just when you thought you liked about
everything on the buffet they bring out
a steam tray full of like [ __ ] fried
gold not only does this movie accomplish
all of those miracles and stand out as
one of the best summer movies I've ever
seen in my life
just when the credits roll on this
[ __ ] and you're like [ __ ] I feel bad
for the next [ __ ] movies gotta follow
this [ __ ] Jesus this got me shooting my
webs all over to join then this movie
somehow bests itself by coming up with a
mid credit sequence that is as dazzling
spellbinding game-changing dramatic
adventurous escapist it does the entire
job that the movie just did for like two
hours and then does it again in the span
of like two minutes in that two minutes
they somehow made a movie that was
better than the amazing movie that they
just showed us for two hours can you
imagine that you get done with the feet
of a lifetime where you're like look at
this not only is it like the [ __ ]
umpteenth Spider Man movie but it's
amazing we've pun intended and it ain't
amazing like the other one it's it is
described as amazing
not in the title not only did they stick
the landing man they they they they
Peter tingled all of us they tingle all
our Peters man it was it was fantastic
it made me go I stood up and I applauded
said John Watson's director for the ages
that was with the movie proper and then
you know I'm like Iron Man show so I
can't wait to see what the post-credits
sequence the mid-credits sequence gonna
be and they show you a mid-credits
sequence that changes the entire face of
the [ __ ] Marvel Universe going
forward changes everything you thought
you knew about what would be next for
spider-man I was having a [ __ ] blast
in these movies man they got high school
right these spider-man movies been a
couple of pitch-perfect high school
movies they're so good you know how
something is you know you know how you
know something's good if you're a
creative yourself or if you fancy
yourself creative you see it and makes
you want to do something like it now
seeing spider-man homecoming and far
from home didn't make me want to make a
superhero movie I don't have the talent
for that but it made me want to make a
high school movie so badly this kid and
his team of writers knocked it out the
park both times with movies that are set
and [ __ ] high school it's difficult
man particularly like any capture in the
tone of high school and a and a teenager
is difficult in any period of time let
alone right now in this period of time
let alone when that's not even the main
story the main story is by the way this
teenager puts on a suit shoots webs and
he's bucking the amazing spider-man
order your friendly neighborhood
spider-man so they're making these
perfect pitch perfect [ __ ] high
school movies and as we come into a
close with with spider-man far from home
and you know you've got Peter and MJ
coming off the plane in North New Jersey
mind you as a [ __ ] New Jersey person
oh my god that made me so happy when I
was a kid any time they put New Jersey
in the movies I'd go ape [ __ ] that
doesn't change when you're 48 even
though you've put jersey in movies your
whole [ __ ] career I saw it's a Newark
New Jersey I was like [ __ ] been there
I've been there I exist in the same
world as these spider-man characters and
I know that because they put Marvel
but Marvel put Mallrats in Captain
America I've know I exist in this
universe I could have passed those kids
post blip if you will who knew man so
that's happening there they show two
kids starting to hold hands they play
another Ramones song and you're like oh
[ __ ]
I like this man and they're like
bringing us into a clothes of landing
the same way they brought the other one
in for a landing man like [ __ ]
there's a Ramones song it's high school
life you know I'm like I'm looking
forward to next one next year where we
get to see Peter and his senior year
because they've let Peter Parker be you
know a teenager a kid and that's that's
what these have been so much better than
the other
spider-man movies for that very reason
how long we've spent with the the
teenager Peter Parker who's learning the
responsibilities of being a spider-man
if you will even though he's a boy and
so I felt comfortable and snookered you
know what I'm saying like I was lied to
because I forgot and that's my father
that's how good the storytellers are
they made me forget what I know in every
fiber of my being Peter Parker never
gets a happy ending spider-man don't get
a happy ending man Stan Lee Steve Ditko
created to put upon character that even
when he won he usually [ __ ] lost and
stuff like that so I forgot about that
cuz I'm watching a movie and in movies
everybody wins
except you know like [ __ ] except the
rebels at the end of empire but
generally speaking people always win in
movies and stuff so you know movies
about fictional stuff please don't be
like what about Schindler's List of
course like obviously not every movie
people win and stuff but in these movies
about superheroes and [ __ ] like that
generally it ends on a [ __ ] high note
unless you know people get snapped out
there's more current reference people
like Empire Strikes Back you're showing
your [ __ ] great balls old man you're
right
Snap is more current reference like some
movies do end sadly but generally
speaking everything ends up for heroes
in a moving ship and that that is not
the case historically for Peter Parker
and spider-man he's always [ __ ]
getting a [ __ ] end of the stick even
though he's the hero and they [ __ ]
did it in the movie they gave him the
[ __ ] end of the stick so hardcore in the
post-credits sequence which after ten
years
Marvel movies 22 other Marvel movies now
everyone is trained to wait for so the
credits start rolling nobody in my pack
theater got up because everybody's like
this ain't [ __ ] done but we all
thought there'd be a little PS that's
just like Oh with some fun little bits
or something like that no instead what
we get is Peter finishing his swing with
MJ through the city they land in front
of Madison Square Garden Madison Square
Garden got that big screen up and stuff
not the big screen as a news break
where they show footage from Mysterio
right before he died Quentin Beck
spoilers he dies in the end we think
we're pretty damn sure he does and you
know there's this off camera footage of
you know spider-man's legs and he's
going like spider-man I was able to get
the dimensional monster and knock him
back into my other dimension but
spider-man just attacked me like turns
and sets up spider-man is the bad guy
which is something we all know from the
[ __ ] comic books but when you think
of like who sets up [ __ ] spider-man
to be a bad guy in the comic books
there's one legendary [ __ ] name three
letters that everybody knows he hates
spider-man as Jay jonah Jameson man and
so what do they do not only do they give
us this marvel cinematic universe
version of Jay jonah Jameson finally not
only did they reinvent it for the time
so the Daily Bugle ain't some [ __ ]
newspaper paper it's the Daily Bugle
dotnet and Jay jonah Jameson is like an
Alex Jones type of guy barking at the
viewer about Patriots and conspiracy
theories and he's talking about Mysterio
died the pager of this world's greatest
hero you know and who did him in but
spider-man he said but that's not it
they had this footage you know that
Mysterio shootin from their final
showdown on the bridge completely
misrepresents our hero but then just
when you're like oh [ __ ] man I'm sitting
there this is brilliant
they just [ __ ] up my boy's life and
[ __ ] now spider-man gonna be a villain
like throughout the city he's right
there in the middle of the city and
everyone's going to turn on spider-man
they took it one [ __ ] step further
man they dismantled my dreams of one
more you know spider-man in high school
movie because nothing will be the same
after this Jay jonah Jameson says like
you know and then you know that's not
all hold onto your hats and [ __ ] because
this piece of information changes
everything and it's Quentin Beck saying
spider-man is Peter Parker and he puts
up a [ __ ] picture of Peter Parker
spills his [ __ ] identity you have of
course you have ever I was gonna say you
have no idea you have every idea you
probably saw the movie and you probably
agree
what a brilliant [ __ ] on-brand
character point for Mysterio that is to
be able to [ __ ] with spider-man's life
even from the [ __ ] grave like oh my
god to bring in a masterstroke that not
only are they bringing j jonah jameson
in but they brought the same j jonah
jameson that everybody agreed they loved
from Sam Raimi spider-man movies pen
they brought in JK [ __ ] Simmons I was
gonna say JK Rowling that would have
been [ __ ] huge right if they're like
ladies and gentlemen playing [ __ ] Jay
jonah Jameson the creator of Harry
Potter go figure
JK Rowling zand [ __ ] and she's like
spider-man can't be trusted
neither can Snape so [ __ ] what a
brilliant piece of fan service that is
man as much as like we were all like
where's Jay jonah Jameson gonna be in
this mess they bring him in and then he
cast the guy who played him in the
movies we all like like it's nostalgia
already in that [ __ ] nuts oh my god
reinventing the Daily Bugle as the Daily
Bugle dotnet and a conspiracy theories
website [ __ ] brilliant like as a
storyteller like I was [ __ ] delighted
that captured my imagination that broke
me of wanting to make a high school
thing because I was like suddenly I
forgot about the [ __ ] delightful high
school movie I just watch and the only
movie I could think about was that
two-minute movie in which they [ __ ]
spider-man's life
never mind the post credit sequence with
Tallis which was pretty [ __ ]
revealing in and of itself and shows his
[ __ ] Nick theory up in space cuz I
guess that's [ __ ] the earth now that's
next they they [ __ ] change the entire
Marvel Universe in a movie that yeah as
the Marvel Studios movie but as a
[ __ ] Sony moving out Disney movie
poom they pivoted it's [ __ ] nuts in
the background you know there's some
construction at the end and you see like
way do you see phase four you know
because that's what's about to begin
they began phase four is such a bang
Kevin Feige modern-day [ __ ] Harry
Houdini let's just pray to Christ he
never gets punched in the ribs and
drowns like the way Houdini died he's
such a [ __ ] magician man you know I
gotta give him credit cuz I think he's
the one consistent you know player
throughout all these movies whether it's
a Disney or these spider-man movies at
Sony like that is fantastic man like
fantastic I mean there was a moment in
the movie where someone referenced
surfboard that was a surfboard [ __ ]
Silver Surfer Fantastic Four oh my god
it's beginning and they didn't never he
just had a surfboard but Kevin Feige
like oh I just wanted to find him and
[ __ ] hug a man he honors the work of
Stan Lee and Steve Ditko by [ __ ] up
spider-man's life I wanted one more you
know
happily ever after high school movie
before Peter goes on to like Empire
State University and becomes grown-up
and has to deal with that [ __ ] and they
did what they did in the comics but Stan
and and and Steve always did and all the
other creators worked on spider-man they
[ __ ] him up they just said yeah it's
not gonna be for our guy he doesn't get
to always win he wins the battle but he
loses the war so this is all just a
preview for the recap this is just me
gone [ __ ] that was spellbinding let's go
back to the top of the movie shall we
and recap the whole flick that I can
remember from the top mind you I've
smoked a big old
caviar joint so I may not details may
[ __ ] fly by but let's try it shall we
okay
aha you could see him talking but he's
not talking cuz he is no longer audible
Jay Mewes here and I'm all about the
audible business shooting out the spider
webs you don't want to listen him you
want to listen to me because I have a
deal for you my friends if you're an
Amazon Prime member and you sign up for
audible guess what you will get the
first three months at 66% off which is
about $30 off which is like three months
of a membership for the price of one
you see this guy Jay Mewes reading a
book is like this ooh ooh squirrel and
then I come back and like where was I
where I'm lost but not with audible my
friends and then this deal is only from
seven 119 to 730 119 and all you have to
do is go to audible.com forward slash
Kevin Smith that's right or you could
text Kevin Smith to 500 500 man there's
so much you can tell you about audible
and what I like about it and what I love
about it I know you'll love it too
probably for the same exact reasons and
you and I will sit down one day and talk
about it text Kevin Smith or go to
audible.com forward slash and let's not
get back ever to this weird weird thing
going on with Kevin thanks muse anyway
back to my review okay not a review
recap
just to recap my position on reviews I I
guess it's technically technically
review not a criticism I can't like
review things properly like people
always telling me oh you just [ __ ]
suck marbles dick that's a proper review
you know look Siskel Ebert had thumbs up
and thumbs down I have dick sucking
that's my [ __ ] brand you know what
I'm saying but I like something I'm like
two hands all over it with a big mouth
so just for those out there who are like
man I just want to see him say something
[ __ ] negative about one of these
movies you won't
I love these movies and you won't see me
review anything negatively cuz there's
no point like if I've already watched
something and I don't like it why am I
gonna waste my time telling you how much
didn't like it [ __ ] you know why you
might like it like you may see
completely different moving them am I
gonna try to talk you out of it but I
will try to talk you into seeing [ __ ] I
like now you know people like ya [ __ ]
marvel really needs the help
it's not about [ __ ] them it's about
me I like chronicling these things just
to capture the moment man I can't wait
to watch these five years from now and
be like wow I mean look number one I'll
be lucky if I'm alive five years now but
to be able to look back and be like look
at all the passion I had before you know
I went completely [ __ ] gray or
something like that is nice my mom likes
him too by the way
but I won't negatively review your
review things I just can't it's not
really in my DNA
I'll tell you it but you'll never you'll
never hear the end about [ __ ] I love and
I [ __ ] love spider-man
far from home you have to realize how
tough a tall order they had with this
flick not only they're following a
really wonderful reboot of spider-man
with the amazing Tom Holland who is
truly a gift to to superhero cinema and
to the character of spider-man in
general one of the only spider-man who
ever spoke with a New York accent
like hi props for that but we're
following endgame which is like the
be-all end-all and insanely satisfying
and you know [ __ ] we had spider-man in
that movie too just like we had him at
infinity work so you know tall order
capturing the magic again you know
you're in a sequel territory now this is
the second of the new spider-man so you
know what are you gonna do if you think
about the Marvel sequels some people
didn't like Iron Man to some people
allowed people didn't like Thor to the
dark world and stuff so there's you know
history not a history and again it's not
for everybody but the same way some
people like hey man with those Star Trek
movies the even ones are good and the
odd ones suck you know the the second
Marvel movie sometime had a tough time
getting out the gate for some not for me
I [ __ ] I loved Iron Man 2 and I loved
and I saw Thor 2 dark world but I loved
guardians galaxies - I thought James
Gunn was able to break that was of that
streak or whatever [ __ ]
that impression I thought that movie
stood out and stuff but some people
Billings book a good Asgardians one
that's the magic of seeing guardians for
the first time then the second time now
you're just into the story of their
world but I love that movie
this was gonna be a tall hurdle clear
because not only have there been another
there's been another spider-man movie
prior to this but we got helpings big
helpings of spider-man in civil war this
same spider-man and then in infinity war
and an end game war I said of that and
you know mind you we had about a decade
of spider-man movies that were not Tom
Holland prior to this as well as
cartoons as well as amazing video games
and stuff one could you know say like
man perhaps there's some spider-man
fatigue or something like that I
wouldn't cuz just like Batman this is a
character that can you could [ __ ]
milk a thousand different ways we just
spider-man just want an Academy Award
into the spider verse right so there was
a chance that people like alright man
[ __ ] enough with spider-man show us
Spider Woman or [ __ ] like anyone else
and they so they had at all at all
[ __ ] building to to clear man first
smart thing they did was adding Nick
Fury because suddenly you're like oh
[ __ ] you're you're Avengers adjacent and
spider-man is an Avenger as we saw an
infinity war so hey tie these together
so we didn't get a lot of Nick Fury and
end games so suddenly it's like oh
here's all but Nick Fury we missed an
endgame they must have met at the
funeral and here we go
that's smart smart taking it abroad you
know it's like there's still high school
kids but they're on a high school trip
so it's not just like oh they're back at
high school Plus after the events of
endgame with kids blip it out and
whatnot you know they had to do
something different and boy did they so
you know that was bright but the most
brilliant [ __ ] thing they did was use
Mysterio as a character I loved this
character I've been a Mysterio fan for
my whole life
ever since I saw him in the cartoon
probably very first place I saw him was
in the old
your man spider-man cartoon my god look
how look at the beauty of this design
this is from the old marvel dolls they
used to do man the toy biz they used to
sell it at KB KB used to be a Toy Story
Toy Story used to be a place you bought
toys before Amazon so I've had this for
a long long time man I love the
character in material I put him in my
daredevil run with Joe Quezada years ago
because I loved that character so much
and was I felt he was always like
underutilized no he's like kind of a
joke they not only included Mysterio who
lends himself to cinematic treatment
because you know he's the master
mister of the mat no that's Doctor
Strange master of mystic arts because he
could do [ __ ] illusions and stuff
like that his whole shtick his [ __ ]
trick and spider-man and everybody you
know no real power he's a special
effects guy from the movies and [ __ ] so
including that character in the movies
was brilliant that characters made for
the [ __ ] movies man but the master
stroke the [ __ ] had upon that the
cherry I don't like cherries the [ __ ]
whipped cream that's good enough why do
people have to [ __ ] make it better
with a cherry like that makes it better
something natural the whipped cream on
the top of the ice cream is Jake my god
he looks [ __ ] Gyllenhaal
I'm not sure that's his real name I
think I looked in the credits that's
what I put in there oh my god he's
fantastic man playing Quentin Beck and
he plays the [ __ ] out of Quentin Beck
you believe him when he's you know
[ __ ] budding up to Peter and you
believe it when maybe that ain't the
case let's go through it so you got
these elements of play they open the
movie with a scene with Maria Hill and
and and Nick Fury going to this town and
in a some other country that's not
America you could tell him American that
I'm like it's someplace not here I
forget which was said maybe Mexico maybe
maybe maybe I think it was a I think I
think it was a Latin country I remember
that correctly something going on
there's a hurricane hurricane a storm
had a face and then suddenly they see
this like
rise up and does have a face and then
this like green smoke hits the ground
and they give you Mysterio in the first
three minutes man there he is and all of
his [ __ ] helmeted glory they didn't
shy away from this [ __ ] [ __ ] any
other era they make this movie
ain't got no glass [ __ ] bubble man
you kidding me they didn't [ __ ] put
the suits on the x-men when they made
that movie the first time it put him in
black leather and they made fun of their
[ __ ] suits in the comics so there was
no chance you were ever gonna get a
bubble headed Mysterio until this day
and age the Marvel Age of movies where
people demand that their characters look
like their characters look like the
characters they've known from the books
forever so boom [ __ ] within the first
three minutes Bowl fishbowl Mysterio on
a big screen I you know I had has that
previously mentioned a little boy next
to me if he wasn't there I would have
just burst nuts in my pants are you
kidding me
and I knew he's gonna be in it I saw it
in the trailer but in the first three
minutes they give me mysterion and then
the bowl disappears the way that like
Tony's face mask disappears the way all
their masks disappear now in the Marvel
Universe nobody takes their helmet off
anymore it's just like to you and it
goes away it disappears and then you see
Jake Gyllenhaal and all his [ __ ]
bearded [ __ ] otter glory it's all I
could say man he's nobody's an otter for
sure
so he's like you know who are you you
don't want any part of this and
dramatically [ __ ] like does Mysterio
hands and [ __ ] and then we cut to the
credit sequence the Marvel card up top
of the movie we're hearing Whitney
Houston singing I will always love you
this is one of the most expensive songs
you could put in a [ __ ] movie number
one
Dolly Parton wrote it number two Whitney
Houston recorded it number three it was
in a hit movie called The Bodyguard
number four it charted topped the charts
for a long long [ __ ] time man so like
in a world of securing songs for movies
[ __ ] like alright yeah I'll give you a
case in point made a movie called tusks
bow a guy turns another guy into a
walrus which is why I never get the call
from Marvel go and come work for us but
in any event meant that many reason
but in that movie tusks I wanted to use
the song tusks cuz I'm I'm that simple
and on the nose and [ __ ] and Fleetwood
Mac I listened to tusk the whole time I
was right in tusk so I was like I'm this
song's got to play in the third act and
[ __ ] and we got it and that song costs
$250,000 to put into the movie we
haven't used the old song put it in the
movie 250th quarter of a million dollars
that song cost more than the walrus
suits that Justin long war in tusk it
was the single most expensive element of
the movie so that's how much music that
you know can cost like when thor
ragnarok used the immigrant song ah that
was like previously one of the most
expensive [ __ ] songs that were put in
the movie so when they open this song
with that Whitney Houston song I was
like [ __ ] man we're gonna see a bunch of
money gets spent this is one giant ATM
man right right off the bat we just saw
Mysterio we just saw a [ __ ] storm
with a face on it and [ __ ] like that
they're just [ __ ] spending the money
oh it's just [ __ ] rain and [ __ ]
make it rain dollar bills man as they
try to get ours from us man that's the
big swindle here right we'll spend a
bunch of money in hopes of getting your
money and they got my [ __ ] money
twice son so the music is playing over a
montage kid made video that's like
homage if you will to the Fallen Heroes
who is black black widow vision and
someone else but then of course Tony
Stark is the last one I think there was
another Avenger who who's a cap Thank
You Josh remind me cap and then of
course Tony Stark and all the images
have pulled off line and [ __ ] like that
the image of Tony Stark is from when he
was on the cover of like time or
Newsweek when they were you know in Iron
Man the very first Iron Man she liked
that has a lot of fanservice a lot of
pulling from other movies to put into
this movie in the way that like the
creators of comic books for years drew
from other stories and referenced him
and stuff like that so perfect so
you see the two kids Betty and the other
guy who did the news in the last movie
last spider-man like homecoming like the
in school news video and they catch us
up to speed on these fallen heroes gave
their life they don't call it the snap
in the movie they call it the blip we
call it the snap because we saw the
movie and we saw fan oh snap
they didn't they just felt the effects
and then [ __ ] felt the aftermath and
then everybody came back they called the
blip people blipped out and like just
like when you know endgame came out
people on line we're like what happened
if you [ __ ] snapped back and you were
in a plane flying in the air like and
then plane wasn't there just follow the
ground and [ __ ] they had a bunch of
people who showed you what happens when
people snapped back like the bunch of
kids it's like [ __ ] bunch of
basketball players disappeared during a
game then at the same gym they were
doing like a band presentation and the
basketball players blipped back in and
[ __ ] ran into him or vice versa so it
was funny but they set up the notion of
like yeah I was [ __ ] up when people
came back they also set up the notion
that some kids blipped away and then
came back and they were still the same
age but the kids that stayed behind aged
in their place so one kid went from
being like a little nerdy kid to being
totally [ __ ] and and hot and studly
and [ __ ] in the five year absence and
that comes into play because that dude
really likes Mary Jane and Peter knows
this so Peter and Mary Jane which wasn't
real at MJ Kensei Mary Jane wasn't
really a thing in the last one cuz Peter
you know really liked the vultures
daughter Liz so this time around though
they kind of you know get right to it
man then he realized at the end of the
movie like oh [ __ ] no wonder they let
them have you know jump to jump into
romance because they're ripping it away
in the next movie so they start noticing
each other liking each other being
interested in each other looking at each
other
furtive eyes flirting and [ __ ] like that
more so than they had in the last movie
at all so and that's not a complaint
you know I it's we talked about it at
the show at the cantina you know people
like that's [ __ ] high school [ __ ]
like [ __ ] him somebody was like maybe
that was a little fast but everyone
that's [ __ ] high school man like
teenage romance moves in stupid ways and
[ __ ]
so these were in a post blip world Peter
really likes MJ he's making plans for
the school trip they're going on he's
telling Ned what he wants to do how he's
gonna like get her up to the top of the
Eiffel Tower and give her this Black
Dahlia necklace cuz she likes the Black
Dahlia because the murders she you know
they paid MJ is like quasi goth kind of
emo and stuff or just like a little left
of center so you know Ned's like don't
do any of that man we're gonna go to
[ __ ] Europe we're gonna be bachelors
man number one there's one thing I know
Americans he goes Europeans love
Americans which is very funny he's
number two like we'll be bachelors over
there man like you don't don't be
getting involved MJ Peter wants to and
stuff meanwhile Peter is working with
Aunt May
she they're having benefits for people
who were victims of the blip people who
were displaced she tells a story about
how she blipped back after five years so
she also was snapped away she in the
snapping her and Peter and everyone
Peter cares about luckily so we can tell
our story and you know she said when I
came back when I blip back you know I
was in somebody else's apartment my
apartment was somebody else's and the
lady thought I was having affair with
her husband so they're having this
benefit and then she brings out like you
know spider-man your friendly
neighborhood spider-man is wearing the
the iron spider armor you know still
from endgame and stuff and talks to the
crowd they raised some blue then he goes
backstage and you know we remember from
the end of the last movie
Aunt May saw Peter with his mask off and
she goes what the [ __ ] and just like at
the end of this movie Peter goes what
the foot and then we go right to credits
when when his thing happens with Jay
jonah jameson so you know clearly
clearly she's cooler than being
spider-man and stuff happy hogan shows
up with a big check from from stark
industries from Pepper Potts you know
and it you get the feeling like him and
may know each other a little bit better
you know as Peters getting a bit of a
Peter tingle about it if you will that's
the notion that's introduced later on
Aunt May introduces the notion of the
spider-sense which we didn't see in
spider-man homecoming but we did see
represented visually with the hair
standing up and in in Avengers infinity
war but in the spider-man movies these
spider-man movies Tom Hollands
spider-man movies the John Watts
spider-man movies because [ __ ]
is a towering talent they haven't done
spider-sense yet but they finally did in
this movie and they and and it may cause
it Peter tingle she's like are you
getting your Peter tingle he's like
don't call it that
so that becomes a running joke
throughout the movie and really funny I
mean they get away with dick jokes and
these spider-man movies now like a Peter
tingle at one point he's got a new suit
on he's like a little tight in the wool
web-shooter around the old web-shooter
and you're like oh [ __ ] these made a [ __ ]
joke in a [ __ ] Disney movie
I love the world we live in today so
Peter getting ready for this class trip
he don't want to bring the suit with him
you know cuz he just wants to chill and
relax he don't want to bring the [ __ ]
you know nanotech suit either which they
show you in its container looks like a
little [ __ ] Red Bull fridge and it's
just like floating and [ __ ] doing
science techy things and he doesn't
bring his old like suit suit either he
just wants to go pack his bag and they
get on the plane man and they skip all
[ __ ] you saw in the trailer about him
picking up his passport and [ __ ] and on
a plane he's got the two teachers with
him JB smooth and Martin Starr we're
also in homecoming and he wants to sit
Peter wants to sit next to MJ buddy sit
next to Ned and Ned wants to play Beast
Wars or some such [ __ ] and let's play a
video game appears got this plan I got a
dual headset jack so we can watch movies
the whole way and stuff and so you know
Ned tells says a Peter needs to switch
with with Betty who's sitting next to MJ
because he's allergic to perfume and and
then suddenly Martin stars like your
large burger you made no joke you just
sit up here Peter and so he winds up
sitting next Martin Starr and the guy
who you know
aged well over five years become hunky
guy he gets to sit next to MJ and there
watching movie together and with the
dual headphone jack and who knew that
was still a thing so they get to Europe
and I think it's Venice first yeah it's
Venice Italy cuz it's all water and [ __ ]
like that and the kids are on the boat I
forgot to mention happy Hogan when he
brought the check to spider-man was like
Nick Fury's calling you in spider-man's
like I don't want to talk to Nick Fury
and he's like you know ghost Nick
furious all that [ __ ] in the trailer so
they set up the Nick Fury's looking for
him and spider spider-man Peter Barger
don't really want to answer it and stuff
he goes on the trip they're in Venice
let me see does this happen before after
yeah the water thing and then he nixed
and then Nick Fury happens so they're in
Venice and they're touring the city and
that's the water city that's on the
canals and water everywhere
suddenly [ __ ] water explodes and [ __ ]
and turns into a giant creature that's
attacking everybody and you know Peter
just like telling Ned get everybody out
of here and stuff he has no masks it's a
big deal he's like I don't have a mask
he's like but nobody's gonna look at my
face he goes and gets like a Carnivale
looking mask to put on and [ __ ] hiding
his identity is the thing with them
because he doesn't want people to see
spider-man in Europe's then people be
like if Peter Parker's in Europe and
spider-man's in Europe Peter programs
biting around the same person you know
they don't want to figure it out [ __ ]
they play with the identity thing a
bunch it's very subtle but they need to
for that [ __ ] third act and [ __ ]
where they rip his [ __ ] identity away
from him [ __ ] so Peter tries to fight
the water monster but his [ __ ] way
big and then out of nowhere [ __ ]
Mysterio shows up and he fights the
[ __ ] water monster and spider-man's
like you know Peter dressed in the mask
being Peter more than spider-man he's
like I can help I'm sticky and he's like
lead him away from the canals material
and so bam they fight him and Mysterio
like takes the water monster out and
[ __ ] everyone's applauding and [ __ ]
saves everybody and does one of these
and [ __ ] takes off and you're like oh
[ __ ] he's a good guy but those of us who
know comics are like yeah he's a [ __ ]
good guy
so you know Peters like suddenly we saw
Peter not be not not that he wasn't
heroic but he couldn't really do much
against something like that which is
weird because they [ __ ] fought Thanos
punch him in the face and [ __ ] got
punched by Thanos but you know Peter
made me feel a little gun-shy in the
absence of Tony Stark his mentor so you
know he goes back to the room at night
and that's where Ned gets tranqued in
the neck Ned and Betty they started
dating on the plane so you know even
though Ned was like let's be bachelors
in Europe he [ __ ] it all up because
he's in a relationship and stuff they
call each other baby fun so he gets
tracked Ned he goes down that's when we
reveal Nick Fury and he says come with
me to Spider Man and he brings
spider-man to down into the guts of the
city to meet Quentin Beck who is a hero
from another earth a different earth
than ours and you know that after the
snap or whatever other dimensions were
opened up and he came here from a
dimension that's not our dimension like
setting up a multiverse as we saw in the
trailer but I knew his [ __ ] even in
the trailer I was like they ain't doing
it ain't doing a multiverse they're
gonna leave that for DC Marvel's got the
entire galaxy they've got the universe
they're like we're not we're not gonna
tell stories about other versions of our
characters we're gonna show you all the
other [ __ ] characters that exist
rather than being like oh here's dark
spider-man and [ __ ] they're gonna be
like here's the Eternals [ __ ]
we got a deep bench so they trick him I
mean he's throwing it out there he's I'm
I'm you know my world was destroyed by
these elementals fire air you know earth
water whatever the [ __ ] and so I you
know fire destroyed my world he was the
most deadly and he killed my family and
[ __ ] all super rogue [ __ ] that you're
like I buy this which is the point and
so Nick Fury is like you're gonna team
up with with [ __ ] this guy and he
said because like you know [ __ ] Stark
believed didn't he we trusted in you and
[ __ ] left you these glasses and happy
give him the glasses or [ __ ] or was
it no it was Nick Fury
gives them these glasses inside there's
a little note and it says to the next
for the next Ironman or something like
that from TS so you know Peters got
these glasses but doesn't really know
like what to do it was just bequeathed
to and more or less but Nick Fury you
know he's like I can't fight these
monsters and that's the moment from the
trailer where dick fares like bit she
pleads you've been to space so he's
gonna team up with Mysterio they know
this monsters headed toward Prague the
first Peter don't want to go he wants to
go on his trip so he tells you know Nick
Fury I don't want to do this and [ __ ]
and he's like oh okay
[ __ ] off so he goes back but then his
teachers are like hey man the tour group
like updated us we're going to Prague
and that's when he's like I think Nick
Fury just hijacked our summer vacation
so in Prague he's set up you know to
[ __ ] watch from the fire monster
that's coming and there's big carnival
going on and [ __ ] and his friends he
makes sure they get put safety going to
an opera with the teachers and whatnot
and Peter goes with them and he's gonna
hang out with MJ and you could tell
they're getting tighter but then he's
got to go off on his [ __ ] mission
instead help Nick Fury and Mysterio and
so they had that moment where like Peter
same thing they didn't in homecoming
where Peters at the party and then he
goes to leave and he looks back and he
looks at the life he doesn't get to
enjoy because he has responsibilities
with great power comes great
responsibility is this tiny [ __ ]
moment but it really makes everything
because you just see this is a boy this
was beautiful about the spider-man story
he's a boy he's a boy who'd just like to
do boys thanks kid things he's a kid
like he just wants to he didn't want to
go the Opera but he just wants to sit
next to MJ and if I can get a
relationship going and stuff like that
but instead responsibilities so off he
goes meanwhile MJ is kind of clocking
him so she tries to follow him and then
Betty and Ned are like [ __ ] they're
leaving look I bet you're going to
Carnival let's go so they head out and
[ __ ] like that
so now the stage is set for the next big
set piece and you know mind you
like Peter Nick Fury have the Peter and
Mysterio have a conversation you know
they were petered Mystery's like Nick
Fury won he'd come up here and apologize
he said he felt bad spider-man's like
really and he's like you know you do
have sarcasm on this earth don't you
so he sits and has a man'd boy chat
sounds [ __ ] dirty but it has like an
adult two minor that sounds dirty to all
the sounds [ __ ] like pedo talk he has
a conversation with Peter and it's very
reminiscent of a mentor having a
conversation with a mentee or meant
whatever [ __ ] the way Tony Stark used to
talk to Peter you know and so suddenly
you're looking at a bearded guy who's
being real nice to the kid and give him
a life advice that's more about like the
hero game is blah blah blah you know
what do you want Peter and he's like I
want to I want to you know be with the
girl and stuff and he's like go go be
with the girl and that's that happened
before Nick Fury [ __ ] took over their
vacation so now the stage is set Peter
and Mysterio working together and stuff
and like at one point you hear them like
he's like I'm in the tower Peter says
I'll let you know when I see anything
had Mysterio goes on your lead
spider-man like oh and I [ __ ] love
that I love that so much Mysterio and
spider-man working together for a minute
and the spider-man believed him that
that was the [ __ ] case and having the
benefit of knowing there's never gonna
be a [ __ ] case because it's Mysterio
and [ __ ] oh it was fantastic so the lava
monster fire monster shows up they fight
it mysterious fight net [ __ ] spider-man
fighting it monster turns his attention
on Ferris wheel and Ned and Betty so
Peters got saved them but he's wearing a
black suit he got this black suit I
probably left off a lot of [ __ ] I did
before this happens there's this hole on
the road to Prague things let me step
back so they give him a new black suits
even bring he brought us his Aunt May
packed his suit for him which we saw him
a little funny bit when he first got
there but they want to get my stealth
suit because Peters like they can't see
spider-man in Europe because Peter
Parker's in Europe and if they see that
they're gonna know that I'm spider-man
once again establishing how an identity
and secret identity is really important
to Peter so they have shield or whatever
organization Nick Fury is in charge of
now because shield has gone
makes up a new black suit that's the
suit you see spider-man wearing and the
trailer so flip up eyes and you know
meets Peter at one point on the road
when the bus is taking all the kids to
Prague the bus that was arranged by Nick
Fury and the driver of it was one of his
like mercenary dudes
so Peter you know is called into the
side room by this lady and she's like
this is a suit I made for you put it on
and you never seen her before it's not
like you know it would have been it
seemed like a place you couldn't put
Pepper Potts but I guess for what
they're about to do would be weird so
she's like take off your clothes
put this on take off your clothes
Peter's getting undressed takes his
pants off and then that dude who grew up
I forget his name Brad I don't know you
know who likes MJ just like Peter sees
Peter with his pants down with this lady
and he's like whoa when he takes a
picture and he's like I'm telling MJ bro
and she had Peters like what the and the
lady's like goes to shoot him Peter
stops him and stuff so Peters nervous
cuz now this guy's got a picture that he
says he's gonna share with MJ of Peter
and in flagrante delicto with this lady
and shits gonna have a lot of explaining
to do
so Peter puts on these glasses that Tony
gave him when they're on the bus right
and the glasses come to life and talk to
him like hello Peter and they scan him
and [ __ ] like that Tony has left in
Peters care his AI tech called Edith and
this is one of the funniest moments in
the entire movie when Edith finally says
what her name he doesn't acronym either
goes Edith stands for even dead I'm the
hero
so Tony Stark built this before he died
the [ __ ] name did that knowing he was
probably gonna [ __ ] die and how [ __ ]
in character is that Tony Stark there's
some flashback footage of me in this
movie but there's no current Robert
Downey jr. in the movie but you might as
you might as well be in the [ __ ]
flick he's felt everywhere and that is
the most Tony Stark iasts in the entire
[ __ ] movie even dead I'm the hero
he's so [ __ ] wonderfully arrogant so
these glasses allow Peter to see tech
interrupts taxi people with their
texting each other and stuff and he sees
that that this kid's about to text MJ
the picture of him
so he's like I gotta stop Brad and you
know Edith as we learn is a high-tech
[ __ ] defense and offense system
satellite up in space so Peters like you
know stop him and so it launches a
[ __ ] drone from space that's gonna in
this the first drone we see of many
that's gonna Zone in on and kill this
[ __ ] kid on the bus and Peter there's
a bit of comedy with the glasses on and
Peter talking and people talking to
Peter and him answering them and not to
the Edith system and each system
mistakes it for her and for Peter
talking to her and so she's launching
[ __ ] drones I'm gonna kill people and
Peter's got to save the [ __ ] bus and
[ __ ] like that but they set up through
that wacky little action sequence that
Peter is in charge of
multibillion-dollar tech and he nearly
almost killed somebody with it so that's
when Nick Fury is like you're in Vienna
vogue and he put you in charge all those
techie almost killed somebody with a
giving Peter the [ __ ] guilties that's
when Peter has the conversation later on
Mysterio and stuff so you know Peter and
like I said now we're jumping back to
the attack the fire monster is attacked
Prague and [ __ ] Peter and pitbull
night monkey as they're calling him
because Ned is in the ferris wheel with
with with Betty and she's like is that
spider-man and Ned you know he's still
Peters man and the chair he's trying to
keep a secret [ __ ] and he's like nah man
died spider-man as a ripoff knock off
cheap European version they got over
here and she's like was he called he's
like night monkey and so she's like
night monkey night monkey save us looks
up him like what and he notices his
friends are in there while the fire
monsters trying to attack and so at one
point Peter launches his web-like to try
to get to the ferris wheel and [ __ ] but
it hits like a force field and comes
down and he's like what but shits going
on so fast confusing that piece of tech
falls to the ground and [ __ ] MJ who's
been watching some of the [ __ ] grabs it
and [ __ ] spirits got webbing all over
it she's trying to figure out a mystery
of her own
so Mysterio you know is like you gotta
keep him away from the power if you
power he'll get bigger he gets bigger
the thing gets bigger mysterious like
I'm not gonna let what happened in my
home world happened here you think I'm
gonna deters like what are you gonna do
spider-man heard mic monkey he's like
what are you gonna do he's like what I
should have done last time he [ __ ]
like haha does a Tony Stark like charge
into the heart of the beast and then
[ __ ] blows him up from inside they
find a stereo Quentin back laying on the
ground and spider-man runs over to be
like oh my god he's been busy trying to
save Ned and Betty from a falling
[ __ ] Ferris wheel so he finds Quentin
back he's still alive and he's like did
we get him he's a yeah we got him and
[ __ ] and so they saved the [ __ ] day
and then Quentin Beck's like you know
let's go out and get a drink so they're
at a bar in Prague and you know he's
talking about Quentin and spider-man are
talking about Mysterio and spider-man
who talk about what just went on and
what Peter really wants he's like what
do you want Peter and he's like I just
want to like be a kid that's one go kiss
a girl kiss MJ and blah blah blah and
you know he's he's like 1 point
somebody's like you dropped these the
glasses and he's like they were just on
the floor and he's like yeah he's like
you know the glasses he's like here he's
like put him on let me say Peter puts
him on and he's like you know Mysterio
goes they look really stupid
and he goes you put him on and so
Mysterio puts on the glasses and for one
second you get the impression of Tony
Stark it's so [ __ ] sinister it like
even Ross for the audience like you know
look piano cue the right music you could
sell anything and they put this [ __ ]
cue under it where you're like that's
Tony Stark right there man that's his
mentor and [ __ ] so Peters like you know
what these glasses are supposed to be
for the next Ironman and he's like that
ain't me he's like mr. stark knew that I
was a [ __ ] and he knew all my [ __ ]
[ __ ] up so he knew he would never be
able to trust me with Edith but like he
wants I think he wanted me to pick
somebody his successor er so I'm given
the glasses to you and he Mysterio is
like are you sure and he's like yeah man
you like you're coming here on this
world now he's gonna be going to Berlin
with [ __ ] Nick Fury you know to
present them to the
[ __ ] world counselor whatever be like
there's a new hero almost making an
Avenger [ __ ] and so you know Peters like
yeah man this is the Rhino and my heart
hearts is the right thing to do so he
tells Edith he's like you know I'm out
of this now it's gonna give it to
Quentin back he takes the glasses and
[ __ ] and he's like I'm out of here and
he goes to find MJ and Mysterio and him
shake hands and off he goes as he exits
the building goes around the corner
you know we seen him go through the
windows the room starts [ __ ]
digitizing and [ __ ]
and you realized that this [ __ ]
has been stung they just pulled the
sting on him and [ __ ] this was a sting
worthy of [ __ ] Newman and Redford man
and Redford's but in these [ __ ]
movies man so everybody's disappear and
except the key players man like real
people of everyone else just Holograms
everything else the life in the bar
total Holograms they come back to
Quentin back and still wearing the
glasses and [ __ ] they're all quiet
and [ __ ] once Peter's completely gone
out of view he's like that was so hard
was it and everybody's like blue and
they celebrate and you realise as they
give you X position they spoon feed you
villain exposition but they do it in
such a great way you realize that
Mysterio is not a man but a team team
Mysterio and a lot of them are made up
of not all of them disgruntled Stark
industry employees this is a stroke of
brilliance for some reason I remember
like I forget I think it was when I
talked to Markus and McFeely like here
when we review when we're talking about
endgame with him me and Mark they said
something about like everything comes
back and gets referenced and they said
like remember the barf technology that's
gonna play a role like even that wasn't
just something like the barf technology
was at the beginning of civil war first
movie we introduced spider-man into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe Tony is is
kind of seeing his parents and a young
version of him reliving a memory and
then you know it starts disappearing in
the same way that the room started
disappearing in the bar that we just saw
disappear the wireframe and [ __ ] like a
special effect design
Tripta bear that same [ __ ] system
that Tony was like you know I spent 250
million dollars and further than this
called barf a bad name and [ __ ] Tony
didn't strictly invent that himself we
reveal as Quentin Beck starts [ __ ]
doing the villains speech a celebratory
villian speech because they're all
celebrating no expansion [ __ ] so he
starts talking about what they've all
just accomplished in order to get the
glasses back whole thing has been a
[ __ ] scam the whole Mysterio thing he
said at one point we first met Peter
when you know he introduced the notion
of the multiverse Peter was just like
confounded by this and then you know he
says a bunch of scientific things and
Nick Fury looks at him and like what and
Mysterio's like never apologize like I'm
sorry and he's like never apologize for
being the smartest guy in the room Peter
like right away setting the tone for the
mentor relationship and he says
something about being smart guy as well
he's like there was smartest people in
the [ __ ] room but nobody will listen
to them anymore nobody listens anybody
unless you got a cape and you could
shoot lasers from your hands he's like
well I got a cape and now I could shoot
lasers from my hands so this guy
invented the barf technology they show
you that civil war scene where Tony
Stark's like I call it barf and they cut
to an angle where suddenly Jake
Gyllenhaal's backstage watching this
thing and he's like my life's work is
called barf like he was [ __ ] over by
Tony Stark then they also show William
who is a character who was an Iron Man
the guy that that Jeff Bridges yelled
that when he was like Tony Stark built
this in a cave you know and all that
[ __ ]
and he's like I'm not Tony Stark that's
William that's played by Peter
Billingsley Peter Billingsley you
remember from a Christmas story you know
he's Ralphie and [ __ ] so he was in Iron
Man he's friends with a Verone [ __ ]
this is I think one of the first times
he's been back man they brought him back
as a character that was also a stood you
know and like [ __ ] all these people
one of them's named Victoria that's one
of the producers on the movies Victoria
Lanza was real cute that a screenwriter
in their group all these people been
burned by [ __ ] Tony Stark by the you
know [ __ ] drunken manchild and [ __ ]
that the party boy and you know now that
he's gone they he was gonna leave this
multibillion-dollar [ __ ] defense
system that they all helped build in the
hands of a [ __ ] teenager so they were
like you know [ __ ] it this is what we
had to do and now we got it
and now Mysterio will be the greatest
hero of all time and people will finally
[ __ ] listen to us and [ __ ] because we
speak from this guy and blah blah blah
so the whole thing is [ __ ] Looney
Tunes man's big scams big lie it's
exactly [ __ ] Mysterio in the comics
like he never did the story in the
comics this is hands down the best
incarnation of this character but it is
so true to everything that character
[ __ ] stands for immense spellbinding
so suddenly like we we know what's up
Peter don't know what's up Peter John's
go back to his life and meanwhile at the
hotel they're like all our parents want
us home and there are monsters here j.b
smoove has like killer - - killer lines
where at one point you know he's talking
about a [ __ ] going on and he's like
somebody says what do you think it is
he's like as a man of science which is
and at what point later on he's like we
got to leave Europe because we came for
science we're leaving cuz of witches and
so Peter sees MJ MJ sees Peter and they
play a little flirty-flirty in the
hallway and then she's he goes to knock
on her door and she opens it hey you
want to go out I'm gonna go for a walk
and yeah and so they have a quiet time
to go I walk and have a conversation and
so you know Peters getting ready to tell
MJ that you know he likes her so he's
like I am and she's like spider-man I
know he's like what I'm not spider-man
and she starts piecing together going
like you're never there you know in
Washington you disappeared and stuff
she's like look that one girl in our
class thinks you're a male prostitute
and he's like I'm not a male prostitute
she's like then you're spider-man and so
she's got that she's like look
spider-man you know he's like we would
there was a guy here that saved people
he's like that's night monkey I read
about that guy's the night monkey and
she pulls out that piece of tech that
she picked up got web all over she's
like night monkey use the same webbing
spider-man uses and then it drops and
[ __ ] all the sudden it turns on and
projects like that [ __ ] cloud monster
this giant monster and [ __ ] and they're
like what the [ __ ] is that and it
disappears and
like that's like a hologram or something
like that and they click it again and
[ __ ] it comes back up and it's just
moving across them and ship at the same
time Wilson Peters like who would do
that and Mysterio comes into view in the
hologram and he's like oh no he's like I
just he realizes what he did what he did
was wrong and [ __ ] like that so he tells
MJ he goes um I am spider-man and she's
like what she's like you're not [ __ ]
with me are you she's like you know cuz
I was I when I asked that was 63 percent
sure or something like a 67 percent sure
he's like I am but I got I did something
really bad and I gotta fix it and [ __ ]
like that so you know you get out of
here and blah blah blah I gotta go do
this
aw he goes to try to find Nick Fury if I
remember correctly or Nick Fury finds
him and then brings him into this office
and you know he starts laying it on the
likes meanwhile they showed you know
Quentin back and his team Mysterio
building the next illusion like you know
and it's the illusions are all made of
drones these giant [ __ ] drones that
you know cast holographic images to hide
what they are but inside they're drones
with weapons so these Holograms could do
real damage that's what William brought
to the project Quentin Beck told us when
he was like and William you know you're
weaponized drones and [ __ ] so suddenly
they can make an illusion that impacts
so it can destroy a canal it can knock a
tower over and something like that
because it's all these drones doing it
inside the illusion so you know Peters
like I you know I realized that I just
gave it a give him the glasses and [ __ ]
like that blah blah blah and then all of
a sudden like the room you know he goes
wait spider gets it he gets a Peter
tingle and he goes Becca's here Mysterio
is here and the room starts disappearing
and [ __ ] you wireframe and you and Nick
Fury is still there and you realize that
he's like [ __ ] like he's real but
everything else is an illusion and
that's when they [ __ ] kick open the
doors of the Mysterio mindfuck sequence
which is fantastic is beautiful it's
everything that you want to see Mysterio
[ __ ] do including like take you know
have it take off his head and shake
like a [ __ ] snow globe because Peters
trapped inside of it with snow in a city
he multiplies himself it's Pete it's
Mysterio [ __ ] with Peter get in his
head with all these illusions and
creating a world around him like when
they did this in the comics the artists
you know had imagination to go wild and
draw things trippy to show spider-man
freaking out and stuff as his mind is
attacked this this is done in a movie
like you know what remember and this
ain't like raisin lowering one to raise
another but remember in Batman Begins
like whenever scarecrow like [ __ ]
work to dust magic and [ __ ] and people
inhale and they see [ __ ] my god this is
that dialed up to 11 times [ __ ] 10
it's just a fantastic sequence I keep
saying fantastic but it's a marvelous
sequence in which Mysterio gets inside
the head of spider-man and you don't
know what's real and spider-man's [ __ ]
with and [ __ ] and he [ __ ] with them to
the point where like Nick Fury gets shot
but then all of a sudden it's not Nick
Fury and spider-man is outside then he's
[ __ ] inside and mysterious telling
him all these things Peter you can't do
this you're about I'm blah blah blah
just just doing what you do in the
comics and eventually pushes Peter out
like you know into the path of a moving
train you know suddenly the illusion
stops and you see Quentin Beck there and
he doesn't have Mysterio gear on and
showed he's wearing a mocap suit motion
capture suit like they do to make these
[ __ ] movies in an ironic bit of
commentary and reality pops back in and
pull [ __ ] spider-man gets hit by train
and disappears so Quentin back as a
[ __ ] killer like not only are there
like we want revenge on Tony Stark and
we want the eat of Technology they're
willing to kill people in fact like now
that they've got to eat of Technology
they're going into London because
they've got to tie up loose ends kill
anybody that knew Peter and [ __ ] that
might know Peter secret and also put on
an Avengers level [ __ ] threat that
will prove Mysterio's greatest hero of
all time and ensconce them [ __ ] and
you know that he wants to Quentin Beck
wants to dial up the weapons on the
drones like into heavy damage and the
like that's gonna kill a lot of people
and it's gonna cause a lot of casualties
and he goes hey man
Londyn they'll rebuild but like you know
we got to do this and so these things
are gonna [ __ ] kill and he knows he
wants to kill Nick Fury and Maria hill
and all Peter's friends
he thinks Peters dead now but [ __ ]
Peter ain't dead climbs up onto the top
of the [ __ ] train from the bottom of
it [ __ ] and gets inside the train car
and goes passes out and wakes up in jail
in the Netherlands and [ __ ] with a bunch
of nice dudes in jail and then he goes
out and he thrusts the lock and leaves
he walks past the guy the end of the
chief detective and he's wearing the
night monkey mask he's a god night
monkey and stuff like that and so Peter
goes out into the little town and
borrows a guy's phone he's like these
people are so nice and he calls somebody
and it's happy Hogan and stuff so you
know Tony's jet comes and lands in a
field of [ __ ] tulips or whatever
where peter is and happy gets out and
he's like Peter and happy he's like
happy is that you which I [ __ ] loved
like he was mine [ __ ] and he's like
don't come any closer like it was it was
so [ __ ] cool man the notion that he
was scared because he doesn't know
what's [ __ ] real anymore and for all
he know because when the illusion ended
another illusion started just when it
looked like somebody was killed they
were alive so he's all mine [ __ ] and
so he don't know if Happy's happy and
he's like tell me something only you
would know and Happy's like you rented a
[ __ ] adult movie last time like when
we were in Berlin he's like alright so
he jumps on the plane with him and happy
sown Peter up because he's been beaten
up and she got black [ __ ] train and
Peter gets all pissy cuz it hurts
there's a really good moment where he
goes you know [ __ ] I thought you had
super-strength and he goes it still
hurts I was still fighting the delivery
of Tom Hollands line where he's like
still hurts like was so [ __ ] real and
it said so much where you're like wow
man so like it's one thing to have those
superpowers but like when he feels a hit
he feels a hit like it still [ __ ]
hurts and still he kind of goes through
with it little tiny hero a moment and
then he [ __ ] out and starts yelling
at happy like haha he's like I [ __ ]
[ __ ] up and mr. stark blah blah blah
and [ __ ] trusted me and blah and so
you know that's where Favreau who
[ __ ] hats off to this guy he
at all this [ __ ] right like Ironman one
of the best [ __ ] movies ever made
he established with Kevin Feige the
[ __ ] Marvel Cinematic Universe so to
have him there I'm so loved that like
they're bringing him back in and he's a
major player now and the spider-man
movies and [ __ ] still a part of the
universe because he's the closest thing
we got to Tony Stark at this point he
was tight with Tony man pepper and and
him the three of them so he says you
know and it's heartbreaking he's like
Tony Stark was my best friend I'm gonna
cry
Tony Stark was my best friend he's going
and he was a mess and I was like oh my
god are they gonna [ __ ] touch on the
alcoholism which they did a little bit
in Iron Man 2 in the comics he was a
[ __ ] alcoholic like Tony Stark him
demon in a bottle very famous storyline
so to have them be like to have him be
like he was you know he was all messed
up he was a mess like I think for me
that includes the alcoholism you know I
went with that in my mind I was like
that's right they're talking about even
that we saw all the heroic acts of Tony
Stark and some slightly less heroic acts
but you know the characters incredibly
[ __ ] rich like and and that
alcoholism thing they did a little bit
of it but [ __ ] runs deep in the
history of that character so I mean
again I I'm not saying that's what they
were saying but for me I was like I took
it but I also just took Favreau been
there from the start
and he's like Tony's my best friend and
he's like but he was a mess and he
second-guessed himself all the time and
whatnot the one thing he never
second-guessed himself about is you and
you know he's like nobody expects you to
be the next Iron Man you just be [ __ ]
spider-man and he chose you because he
believed in you and blah blah blah you
know so you're stranded you're in the
middle of nowhere you ain't got a suit
what are you gonna do and you know he's
[ __ ] invoking Tony Stark he's calling
him up man cuz Tony was lost in the
middle of nowhere in the desert without
his [ __ ] tech and he built Tony Stark
built this in a cave you know what I'm
saying so Peters like I need a suit and
[ __ ] fabs happy Hogan like turns on
the [ __ ] tech and the [ __ ] thing
opens up and this is the moment in the
movie that made me [ __ ] cry so you
know the [ __ ] the optics turn
the holograms and chitons and Peter's
like show me everything you got on
spider-man and all the different
spider-man suit designs are there and so
he pulls one just the way Tony used to
pull him in his lab and he pulls the
hologram and he starts working with it
and he's pulling all he's like lose this
and he puts his hand through it like as
if it's there the way like Tony did with
the glove way back in the day and they
did that and I was like oh my god and
then they [ __ ] cut - Favreau seeing
it which definitely nails home that he's
having a [ __ ] Tony Stark moment - and
that's what [ __ ] breaks your heart
and - man and then he's like you take
care of the tech I'll take care of the
music and he [ __ ] puts a ban ban ban
puts on ac/dc and [ __ ] Peters like I
love Led Zeppelin they're funny so fabs
got to turn that music on which is very
poetics he turned that music on the
first time - an Iron Man as the director
so they're hovering above the tulip
field now they're building the suit
suits getting billed and [ __ ] you
know happy sends a coded message to Nick
Fury saying things may not be as the
things aren't as they appear or whatever
you know letting them know that Mysterio
is not as guy at one point Mysterio you
know they're they're rushing to get to
where the where's the [ __ ] end Oh
London duh the Russian to get to London
where the big thing is about to happen
and we're Mysterio's next big [ __ ]
illusions about to happen and the at one
point Mysterio is like you know fighting
this [ __ ] thing comes up out of you
know it's a giant [ __ ] weather
amounts or some [ __ ] and he's like you
know it's drawing if it gets near this
it'll draw power and get bigger and Nick
Fury is watching this thing from a
window and finally clicks is here
thinking he looks back at Maria hill and
he goes now that's some [ __ ] calls
it for what it is Nick Fury playing the
most Nick Fury version of Nick Fury that
Nick Fury has ever been in this movie
throughout the whole movie you're like
wow man Sam just plain Sam playing Nick
Fury now and then at the end you realize
what was going on it's very [ __ ]
clever nothing bad about the performers
whatsoever it's good really good but
like you said they're gone like he's
hitting some
your note and then you realized why
later on so at this point you don't know
it [ __ ] well we talked about it early
[ __ ] Talos and his and his wife were
pretending to be Nick Fury and and and
Murray Hill the whole [ __ ] time they
haven't been in the movie we don't see
Nick Fury in this movie until the
post-credits sequence when we see him up
in space with the Skrull army you know
where we you know [ __ ] so obviously
he went to the funeral and then he
[ __ ] off with Captain Marvel she was
at the funeral too and they're still
doing whatever they're doing up in space
at one point we hear him say a line
about like a Kree sleeper cell and
you're like holy [ __ ] but that didn't
really register until [ __ ] later on
you're like are they [ __ ] layin seeds
for the crease girl war [ __ ] I mean
lord knows we saw that in Captain Marvel
but they bringing it to earth by saying
sleeper cell like what the [ __ ] so but
that's all I'm passing and [ __ ] so now
Nick Fury's hiked to the fact hip to the
fact that Mysterio ain't what he says
we're seeing Quentin back like on this
bridge away from the action he's wearing
a mocap suit with a giant dome on it
that's where Edith is now not a new pair
of glasses been this [ __ ] dome so he
could control the thing he controls it
on his wrists gauntlet all the different
cameras different drones and [ __ ]
seeing him in the mocap suit is dope but
seeing him in that [ __ ] bubble head
he's still [ __ ] Mysterio you know
clever that is even though he's not
wearing the bubble head he's wearing a
[ __ ] bubble head so in the final act
there's a Mysterio and there's Mysterio
the whole movie we talked about it on
fat man in Batman really does harken
back to Iron Man 3 and also like every
[ __ ] Iron Man movie harkens back to
Tony Stark Tony Stark created all of his
[ __ ] villains including Mysterio like
once again Tony is responsible and the
tech that's gonna kill everybody
Edythe also created by [ __ ] Tony so
even dead he's the hero but even dead
he's still the [ __ ] he created all of
the bad guys that he had to eventually
fight and [ __ ] now he's created a bad
guy that Peters gotta fight in his
absence
so yeah the movie rings very Iron Man 3
in as much as in Iron Man 3 the the
Mandarin was not who the Mandarin was
presented as Mysterio is not who
Mysterio has presented as he's this
[ __ ] team of people [ __ ] with all
these drones so spider-man has to
jump you know Easy's got a suit ready
and [ __ ] he's on the side of the plane
with happy happy meanwhile there's been
a few moments where like [ __ ] you
could tell he likes Aunt May and
spider-man's like when I get back we're
gonna talk about you and May and he
jumps off the plane and [ __ ] flying
squirrels it down and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
lands you know Nick Fury sees him
landing and he's gonna dive right into
the monster so into the illusion Peters
like I gotta get into the heart of the
illusion disable the [ __ ] drones that
always set the [ __ ] up like a video game
so like if you're playing the game
they're like you're the things you got
to do to get inside the monster you got
to shut down all the drones and you got
blah blah blah so they they set up the
tasks for us and Peter's about to do any
bursts inside and [ __ ] you know
Mysterio knows he's in there and Peter
starts webbing up all the [ __ ] drones
and he'd rigged his [ __ ] you know
webbing to carry a charge so they shocks
them all and the illusion starts fading
so the rest of the world this illusion
is attacking and the kids are on the
[ __ ] double-decker bus the
screenwriter of Mysterio like was the
guy who's driving the bus and [ __ ] and
he locks him on the bus real sinister
and whatnot so the kids are in jeopardy
Mysterio was like I gotta where he's
like show me my loose ends eateth and
shows them all the pictures of like Nick
Fury and Maria hill and the kids those
are the people who got to kill while
this big monster events going on but
meanwhile spider-man's ruining the
monster event and [ __ ] you're seeing
all the drones decloaked and Mysterio is
like decloak all the [ __ ] drones and
william's like what he's like don't they
he's like but people will see he's like
they'll see what I want him to say like
he's just [ __ ] nuts
so spider-man you know was fine he's
fighting the [ __ ] drones and taking
him out and [ __ ] like that
meanwhile there's one [ __ ] drone that
was ready to fly Krait in front of Nick
Fury ready to kill him but Maria Hill
runs up the [ __ ] tower the [ __ ]
bazooka and [ __ ] as soon as all the
drones uncloak the one is right out in
front of the window in front of Sam Jack
in front of Nick Fury ready to blow him
away and he's like you got me and she's
like I got you and she [ __ ] blows the
[ __ ] drone out of the sky cheerio
so now spider-man gotta you know do the
the big thing and take out [ __ ]
Quentin back
who's on the bridge and he spots him
through all the [ __ ] atmosphere and
[ __ ] he's like there you are you
sumbitch and he [ __ ] goes in to this
long bridge thing and you know [ __ ]
grabs him and he's like I got you and he
goes well it seemed you had me at a
disadvantage and then one of the drones
[ __ ] blow his Peter to the other end
of the hallway and [ __ ] and then
Mysterio goes for his [ __ ] [ __ ] again
man he's got some drones left and boom
the whole thing blacks out and he's
gonna [ __ ] attack Peter in the dark
cuz now he's the master of deception and
Peter can't [ __ ] see around him and
she'll like that and that's when the
Peter tingle kicks in man and he [ __ ]
you hear him is such a great sequence
you hear him go like breathe in and
[ __ ] Peter tangle it and [ __ ] and
then all of a sudden they do this dark
hallway sequence where he has to take
out like [ __ ] 20 drones and [ __ ] to
get to Mysterio and that's done in
flashes because it's dark tunnel and
anytime he destroys a drone and it blows
up so you see it all in flashes but it's
all meant to be Peter using his spider
sense to do it which is a huge [ __ ]
beat in the movie man boom and he gets
to the end and [ __ ] you know the
drones are like you know he's like fire
everything and Edith is like you we
can't you're in the [ __ ] strike zone
and he's like I don't care so the drones
are [ __ ] firing like crazy and
they've hit [ __ ] Quentin Beck so he
drops down then Peter takes out the last
drone and [ __ ] goes you know to
confront Quentin back and [ __ ] like that
and he's just like laying they're all
[ __ ] busted up and like you got me
kid kind of thing and you know he's just
like you're a good guy Peter that's
you're always gonna be a problem and so
Peter wants the glasses and so Mysterio
goes to him the glasses then all sudden
well Peter like reaches off to the
[ __ ] side you hear a gunshot and he
caught Mysterio's armistice shoot him in
the [ __ ] head he was gonna shoot this
boy this highschool boy with a gun in
his [ __ ] head I know like you know
Peter Parker is dodging death left and
right but that really hit me that
impacted me I was like after all that he
was just gonna [ __ ] blow on his kids
[ __ ] brains out on this bridge like
this nuts man these movies so Peter
caught it and he's like you can't fool
me no more and [ __ ] if I could puts a
he goes down or whatever the [ __ ] so the
guide on the ground was a [ __ ]
illusion and this guy was ready to
[ __ ] kill Peter but he caught it [ __ ]
and then Peters like tag gets the
glasses put him on he's like Edith
executes all she's like killing killing
orders to you know [ __ ] whatever the
drones are doing and she says execute
always and yes execute everything
execute all of them are whatever [ __ ]
it's all the drones power down go back
up to the [ __ ] satellite [ __ ] like
that and Quentin back dies says some
[ __ ] and dies and Peter uses the glasses
goes is he is this real and they're like
yeah so I think he's dead some people
like I don't think he's dead
I think he's [ __ ] dead but he don't
have to be I mean if they want to do a
sinister six Mysterio could still be
alive it just doesn't have to be Jake
Gyllenhaal right cuz he died on the
floor or it could be Jake Gyllenhaal
or it could be Jake Gyllenhaal and said
they were reveal it's a [ __ ] you know
Ralphie from Christmas story work in the
illusion like you know that's but they
ain't gonna touch his character again I
guarantee you for a while because
they're so deep bench over there man
they never look backwards they always
[ __ ] look forwards man so I can't
imagine unless they do a sinister six
which could be [ __ ] spider-man three
the next one you know far from [ __ ] or
whatever they want to call it [ __ ] at
home homeschooled that's what he calls
Spiderman home school and a sinister six
comes to [ __ ] get him and [ __ ] like
that because they've already set up
vulture you got yourself scorpion
now you got them stereo who else you
missing I don't know three new ones they
could add in this [ __ ] in the new
movie
so everything working out [ __ ] you
know well for Peter [ __ ] looks heroic
and whatnot things look like they're
coming in for nice landing as we said at
the beginning and then all hell breaks
loose I'm not gonna recover it recall
that we did that the top remember they
get home [ __ ] you know him and MJ
kiss on the bridge I should talk about
that after the fight they have this
really sweet high school [ __ ] moment
on the bridge where they have this
conversation and kiss and you know it's
it's honestly like in a movie full of
visual wonder and non-stop like action
and and you know a high school patois
the romance is sweet like it makes you
makes your heart beat a little bit
you know we'll make sure well up makes
you remember a time when [ __ ] you
were young and everything and even
though this kid just went through
[ __ ] hell on earth
kissing MJ is the greatest adventure of
his life up until that point so they
nail that man as well and then you know
get him to Newark and [ __ ] let him
swing through the city it ends with them
swinging through seed picks up MJ and
they go swinging like through Manhattan
which is really fun and visually
interesting and breathtaking and then
cut to those cool credits they do and
then cut to the mid credit sequence
where they [ __ ] wreck shop oh my god
is un-fuckin'-believable
so loved this movie loved the
performances once again Tom Holland
fantastic Jacob the kid who plays Ned is
great sand diets and diet wonderful the
all the kids Betty the kid who plays
flash real pissed piece of [ __ ] I hope
they're setting him up to be a bad guy
like maybe Loki right like you know like
they show him his mom not and his dad
not picking him up at the airport but
like his driver picking him up and it
was such a weird like why do you include
that unless that's gonna be useful for
later on you know what I'm saying like
you definitely don't need to be like and
his parents still don't care for him you
know that's not really part of the story
but it's in there and I don't think
they'd do anything accidentally as we
saw barf was not just something to open
civil war it was the entire [ __ ] plot
of spider-man far from home like that
technology so I would keep an eye on
[ __ ] Flash Thompson if I were you
the teachers j.b smoove and Martin Starr
were great Nick Fury who we find out in
the in in the tail credits is not Nick
Fury but Talos both of them were great
he cobie smulders smoldering as always
she was wonderful but man the [ __ ]
MVP of this [ __ ] is definitely
Tom Holland but right next to him
shoulder to shoulder
Jake Gyllenhaal and it's really sweet
because Jake Gyllenhaal one point almost
paid played spider-man back in the day
so he got to be in a spider-man movie
and do something wholly original like
you know I'm not taking anything away
from anybody but if you have the choice
between being one of 12 people that paid
spider-man and the only person that
played Mysterio the way is clear so he
did a phenomenal [ __ ] job human and
it's a performance within a performance
it's like the sting really great [ __ ]
stuff and across the boards this was a
tough act to follow spider-man
homecoming Michael Keaton was so amazing
and that [ __ ] scene when he turned
around he's like I will kill you in the
car and shed as dope and plus his just
his outfit was fantastic that made the
vulture like work and makes sense
they [ __ ] doubled up with him if
Mysterio and delighted this age old
[ __ ] Mysterio fan who got to see his
hero up on the big screen and [ __ ] like
that
with the fishbowl and all man they did
his [ __ ] in the 90s in the arts he would
have had like a [ __ ] mask or some
[ __ ] but they gave him the [ __ ] cloud
a fishbowl man was fantastic um loved
the movie obviously go see it man it is
it's everything a movie's supposed to be
I see a movie like this it makes me a
shame that I call myself a filmmaker
cause I'm like and I don't do that I
don't do that I don't take people on
journeys of wonder and [ __ ] like that
hats off to John Watts hats off to all
the screenwriters is four names and as a
writer I should memorize them all but
they did a [ __ ] great job maybe
there's only two names I forget but a
fantastic script across the boards Amy
Pascal Kevin Feige all those cats
involved man it's it's not far
spider-man far from home but not far
from my heart there it is ah thanks man
don't forget me at Hall H coming up at
San Diego comic-con and soon you're
gonna be seeing a trailer for Jay and
Silent Bob reboot man a far less Webby
movie then spider-man far from home and
far less expensive as well boy we had no
money they have all the money and it
shows they use every [ __ ] dollar well
up on that screen whatever it cost III I
wholeheartedly applaud whatever they
spent making this movie it's movie made
me so happy
so happy I went to see it [ __ ] twice
I'll probably see it another time joy
that's what they're meant Nova the
Marvel Factory man here's some [ __ ]
joy in it marvelous yes it is there it
is man that's that was the very first
sound of Bob speaks but seeing how
chatty I like to be you can [ __ ] be
assured it's not the last so this is
Kevin Smith for Silent Bob speaks until
next time
trademark Kevin Smith